en el último vídeo estuvimos hablando de
variables aleatorias y pues vamos a
seguir haciéndolo en este pero bueno a
ver de las variables aleatorias de las
que ustedes ya saben algunas cosas pues
hay dos tipos de ellas las variables
pueden ser discretas o pueden ser
continuas las variables de tres
discretas toman valores que o sea como
que están separados se pueden distinguir
muy bien y osea otra forma de pensar en
ello es que puedes hacer o puedes contar
las puedes hacer una lista entonces
saber las variables aleatorias toman
valores que están como que separados o
sea que son distinguibles en cambio las
variables aleatorias continuas toman
valores en un rango o sea por ejemplo
toman cualquier valor en cierto
intervalo o cosas de ese estilo y
generalmente hay una infinidad de
valores que pueden tomar
ok toman valores en un intervalo y ahora
pues veamos algunos ejemplos de
variables aleatorias y cómo se definen y
preguntémonos si son variables discretas
y continuas se acuerdan de la variable
aleatoria del vídeo pasado era una x
mayúscula que tomaba el valor de 1 si
salía aguilar
y tomaba el valor cero si salía sol
bueno esta variable aleatoria es
continua o es discreta pues bueno es
discreta no sea porque puede tomar dos
valores que podemos distinguir muy bien
o sea que están separados y de hecho los
podemos contar podemos decir este es el
primer valor y este es el segundo valor
a ver veamos otro ejemplo digamos que ye
mayúscula es la masa
de un animal tomado aleatoriamente
un animal
escogido
aleatoriamente o sea
en el zoológico de chapultepec de la
ciudad de mexico
ok y es exactamente igual a la masa de
un animal escogido aleatoriamente en el
zoológico de chapultepec de la ciudad de
méxico y que dicen es una variable a
thor ya discreta o continua
y creo que me faltó remarcar lo pero
esto es exactamente la masa del animal
que la masa exacta de cualquier objeto
en el universo o sea también puede ser
cualquier animal en el universo puede
tomar una cantidad de valores muy grande
o sea puede tomar cualquier valor en un
conjunto muy grande de valores o sea
quién sabe cuál es exactamente la masa
de un objeto en este momento cuántos
protones hay en ese momento cuántos
neutrones y electrones y moléculas hay
en cierto momento en cierto objeto en
este universo entonces está variable
puede tomar cualquier valor en un
intervalo ok o sea tal vez tenemos
animales muy pequeños o sea y tenemos
aquí una cota del lado izquierdo en el
cero de la hormiga tal vez tiene una
masa pequeña en contraste con otros
animales y puedes encontrar algún animal
más chico que la hormiga algo muy
cercano al cero y de este lado pues no
sé tal vez tienes alguna ballena o sea
podríamos tener
tal vez cinco mil kilogramos o alguna
cosa de este estilo pero si tomamos un
animal pues tal vez ese animal tiene una
masa de nueve kilogramos punto 5 813 4 y
bueno tal vez allí o sea nos detuvimos
ahí pero tal vez esto en realidad tiene
una cola mucho más larga de números aquí
entonces esta variable la masa de un
animal escogido aleatoriamente tomar
cualquier valor en un intervalo y pues
hay una infinidad de valores allí y no
estamos pudiendo distinguir entre por
ejemplo este valor y uno que está aquí
ves súper cercano entonces esta variable
definitivamente es una variable
aleatoria continua continua
y esta habíamos dicho que era una
variable aleatoria discreta no
discreta y bueno ahora vamos a ver otro
ejemplo otra variable a thor ya pero es
otra variable distinta esta y ésta ya no
está y va a ser el año en el que nació
un estudiante de la clase escogido al
azar
ok ya es el año de nacimiento de un
alumno escogido al azar y entonces que
dicen es discreta o es continua
esta variable podría tomar valores por
ejemplo 1993 o 1988 o 2006 y bueno el
conjunto de los años está organizado de
una forma discreta o sea o estás en el
año 2006 o estás en el año 2005 y no
puedes estar en medio de esos dos
valores
entonces estos valores
entonces llegué como toma valores que
están organizados de forma discreta pues
también es una variable aleatoria
discreta
generalmente cuando encuentres con
variables aleatorias discretas pues va a
haber una cantidad finita de valores que
puedas tomar pero no tienen por qué ser
así
o sea una variable la tra discreta puede
tomar una infinidad de valores siempre y
cuando los puedes enlistar o sea puedes
decir este es el primero este es el
segundo este es el tercero y bueno tal
vez te pases toda la vida y te quedas
para siempre alistando los y nunca cabes
pero puedes ordenar y enlistar y contar
puede ser una dirección de los valores
con los naturales y mira como este no es
el caso en el escenario del zoológico no
podemos enlistar todos los posibles
valores que puede tomar la variable
aleatoria ayer osea tal vez podríamos
tratar de enumerar este conjunto y bueno
como lo intentaríamos pues es decir
diríamos ok 0.0001 ok y digamos cuál es
el siguiente número de la lista punto
002 pero qué crees aquí no sacamos a
saltar una infinidad de números los
valores que toman las variables a la
tras continuas no se pueden enumerar ni
enlistar y veamos otra variable
aleatoria no habrá una zeta para
cambiarle un poco digamos que z es la
cantidad de hormigas que van a nacer
mañana en el universo
jay-z es el número de hormigas que nacen
y seguramente ahorita están argumentando
algo así como que el planeta tierra es
el único lugar en el universo en el que
hay hormigas pero están seguros de eso
están seguros que las hormigas no
encontrar una forma de hacer viajes
intergalácticos o que por ejemplo en
algún otro lugar del universo ya se
formó un planeta muy parecido al planeta
tierra donde evolucionó una forma de
vida idéntica a las hormigas aunque
probablemente dirían que esas no son
hormigas entonces el número de hormigas
que nacen mañana en el universo es una
variable aleatoria continua o discreta
pues otra vez es discreta no o sea
porque tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 billones 4
trillones 5 mil millones de trillones
hormigas pues ya podemos enumerar las
hormigas enlistar las entonces otra vez
esta variable es una variable aleatoria
discreta y bueno ya que nos estamos
divirtiendo tanto que sigamos con otros
ejemplos a ver vamos a poner x que vamos
a definir una nueva variable aleatoria x
vamos a redefinir la no va a ser ésta
entonces x va a ser exactamente el mejor
tiempo de la carrera de mujeres de 400
metros en las olimpiadas del 2016
entonces x es exactamente el mejor
tiempo de la carrera ok no precisamente
el tiempo que aparece en los relojes de
los réferis de las olimpiadas sino
exactamente el mejor tiempo
entonces x es una variable actor ya
continua o discreta
pues justo eso que nos enseñan en las
olimpiadas es un poco truculento porque
tal vez el reloj en las olimpiadas
indica 9.56 o 9.57 o en 9.58
pero en realidad el tiempo pudo haber
sido 9.58 1 3245
etcétera y bueno la variable x o sea
exactamente el mejor tiempo de la
carrera pues puede tomar valores entre
porque es bueno los corredores no pueden
correr más rápido que la velocidad de la
luz no de hecho definitivamente no se
van a tardar menos de un segundo en
cruzar los 400 metros y el mejor tiempo
si creemos que va a estar abajo de los
60 segundos entonces aquí es puede tomar
cualquiera de estos valores y bueno esta
es una variable aleatoria continua no
porque hay una infinidad de valores que
puede tomar la variable x osea puede
tomar todos estos y no podemos numerar
todos estos hay una infinidad de valores
y además no podemos distinguir entre
este y el que está inmediatamente al
lado y no podemos enumerar los ahora
algo muy distinto pasa si tachamos eso
de que sea exactamente el mejor tiempo y
le ponemos aquí que es aproximado con
dos decimales
bueno si aquí le quitamos de sol que
tiene que ser exactamente el mejor
tiempo en la carrera y ahora lo
aproximamos con dos decimales entonces
pues no necesariamente tiene que ser
continua no tú qué dices es continua o
es discreta que michael ya borre esos
valores que pusieron los réferis de la
carrera pero los réferis podrían poner
valores como 9.57 9.58 o 9.59 y bueno
puede poner muchos otros valores no pero
como ahora lo estamos aproximando con
dos decimales entonces ahora sí o sea
entre este y éste ya no va a haber
ningún otro valor que x pueda tomar o
sea estos valores están separados y los
podemos contar aunque hay es un buen
ejercicio ver cómo puedes numerar estos
valores
pero el chiste es que es un conjunto
discreto y entonces está hecho y también
es discreta
espero que haya quedado clara la
diferencia entre variables aleatorias
discretas y continuas y veremos otras
cosas